the first time the public heard that
target had been hacked was on December
18 2013 when a blogger revealed that the
company was investigating a massive
breach but the breach itself actually
began sometime before then so what a
target no and when did they know it
hackers began capturing credit card data
on November 27th three days later a
sophisticated security tool made by
fireEye's spotted the malware target had
paid 1.6 million dollars for fire ID
because of its ability to detect hacking
in real time soon
the security worker in India saw the
fire alarm and sent it on to the
minneapolis Operations Center the alert
is overlooked on December 2nd security
tools detect another version of the
malware this red flag also goes
undetected had target acted on the
alerts at this point they would have
been able to prevent one of the biggest
data thefts in history instead for more
than two weeks the hacker software
collected credit card information and
Unbounce it around the globe to places
like Moscow and Odessa mcplank on
December 12th federal law enforcement
notifies target that they are seeing
suspicious activity involving card
payments at its stores the retailer
hires an independent team to run a
forensic investigation and on December
15th target confirms it's been hacked
and removes the Walworth target issues
its first public statement about the
data theft on Thursday December 19
revealing that up to 40 million cards
may have been compromised 22 days later
on January 10th target notifies
customers that in addition to the credit
card theft personal information for up
to 70 million customers has also been
stolen affecting as many as one third of
American consumers